netflix is a treasure trove of science
fiction films but with that vastness
comes a problem of navigating it
fear nuts we're here to help from huge
blockbusters to intimate thrillers
these are some of the best sci-fi movies
on netflix
director bong joon-ho earned a major
victory on the world stage in early 2020
when his film parasite took the best
international feature
best original screenplay best director
and best picture
at the academy awards since then film
fans everywhere have been seeking out
his other work
but if you still happen to be a beginner
snowpiercer might be your perfect bong
joon ho getaway
like parasites the film is a dark
satirical look at class
however snowpiercer leans heavily into
science fiction
it takes place on a train which carries
the remnants of humanity in an
endless loop around the world after it
was left frozen
in the wake of a cataclysmic event
featuring tremendous performances from
chris evans and tilda swinton snow psa
documents the rise of a resistance
movement
to take back the train from the elite
upper class that controls it
this is going to be good
in the years before making his direct
troy your debut with ex machina alex
garland established himself as a
talented sci-fi writer
through screenplays for 28 days later
and 2012's dread
for his first film as a director garland
poured those instincts into a science
fiction thriller exploring artificial
intelligence the hubris that goes hand
in hand with genius
and what happens when it all collides in
an extremely remote mansion
ex machina is a story of a programmer
named caleb who wins a visit to the
secluded home of nathan bateman
an enigmatic tech genius played with
brilliant abandon by oscar isaac
batham reveals to caleb that he's built
a robot who might be able to pass the
turing test
[Music]
do you have a name yes
ava over the next several days caleb and
ava grow closer
and it becomes clear that she is much
more than just an intelligent robot
ava is forming a plan and her human
keepers are part of it
whether they like it or not if you're
looking for an intimate tense sci-fi
thriller with big ideas and big
performances
ex machina is for you for some reason
minority report feels like a somewhat
minimized entry in the steven spielberg
filmography
perhaps it's because pop culture's
memory for sci-fi blockbusters keeps
getting shorter
or maybe it's because a film falls in
spielberg's career between beloved
classics like jurassic park
and later films that didn't always
connect with long-time fans like indiana
jones and the kingdom of the crystal
skull
still whether you haven't seen the film
since it was released or you're just
eager for something new to watch
minority reports is well worth
remembering the sci-fi action film stars
tom cruise as a police captain working
in a pre-crime division that predicts
and stops homicides before they happen
until one day a prediction reveals that
he himself is set to be a killer very
soon
this intriguing setup allows crews to do
some of his best man on the run work
while also allowing spielberg to
simultaneously deliver high concept
science fiction
the result is a tremendously
entertaining sci-fi thriller
sometimes the best sci-fi films are the
ones that can take a very direct
metaphor and present it in a way that's
both visually compelling
and intellectually surprising and
district 9 is one of those movies
direct daniel blomkam's breakout film
tells the story
of an alien species who came to earth
and was eventually herded into
internment camps by the south african
government
beginning with that premise the film
focuses on the story of a government
worker who goes inside the camp to serve
eviction notices and engage
with the aliens there you go eat your
sweetie
he's gonna eat his sweetie
the worker soon finds himself undergoing
profound physical and psychological
changes
after coming into close contact with a
piece of alien technology
district 9 was one of the most acclaimed
films of 2009
earning an academy award nomination for
best picture and launching blumkamp into
a career that has since produced
major films like chappie and elysium
starring matt damon
years after its release district 9
remains one of the most respected
and impactful sci-fi films of the 2000s
and it helps spawn a new wave of
thoughtful movies about alien
interactions with humans
spike jones movies have always defied
easy classification
from the unexpected world of being john
malkovich to the meta zaniness of
adaptation
jones films retain a sense of raw and
honest humanity
even when they're expanding into
outlandish territory however of all his
films
her might actually be the most human
which is saying something when you
consider the subject matter
written by jones himself her is the
story of a lonely man who finds himself
striking up a friendship
and later an intense romantic
relationship with an advanced operating
system named samantha
on the surface this might seem like a
one note bit of storytelling but with
brilliant performances from joaquin
phoenix amy adams and scarlett johansson
as the voice of samantha
jones expertly explores the various
implications of the relationship
and the way the world responds to it
beautifully crafted oddly funny
and full of emotional surprises her is
unlike any other major sci-fi film of
the last decade
in 1999 the wachowskis released the
matrix and science fiction cinema hasn't
been the same
since the film is about a young hacker
who learns a world he knows is really a
simulation
and he's been drafted as a messiah in a
battle against humanity's machine
overlords the matrix offered moviegoers
mind-blowing wire work
groundbreaking visuals and the kind of
philosophical underpinnings that have
come to define
so many 21st century sci-fi blockbusters
it's an essential film for action fans
science fiction fans and movie fans in
general in fact
its influence can still be seen in
countless films and television shows
the matrix is everywhere in the spring
of 2020 the matrix returned to netflix
but this classic didn't come alone you
can also watch the two sequels matrix
reloaded and
matrix revolutions granted they can't
quite live up to the trailblazing impact
and influence of the original movie but
they still have plenty to offer reloaded
features some of the best action
sequences of the entire saga
and revolutions as a classic case of
time being very kind to a film that
leans heavily into the philosophy of its
story
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
movies on netflix are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you